et il appuyé sur ce bouton moi j'ai
continué à parler et cinq minutes plus
tard il ya des hommes cagoulés qui sont
rentrés dans gg haut l'équivalent du
gène en belgique qui est arrivé qui a
bloqué la route avec deux camions noir
[Musique]
on va jouer avec l'abus de confiance
l'abus de confiance et le mensonge et le
renard
les chroniqueurs sont ils des arnaqueurs
qui n'est le meilleur arnaqueurs nous
allons le voir chacun va venir raconter
une histoire
un auditeur votre téléphone s'il dit
l'histoire est vrai qu'elle est vraie il
gagne une clé qui correspond à ses
coffres ouvrir le coffre
il gagnera ce qui est à l'intérieur à la
fin avec toutes les clés gilles de quoi
s'agit-il
l'orage gronde sur cuba la justice ça
reste un jeu
l'orage gronde sur cuba en tout cas ses
cheveux l'orage gronde sur cuba nous
sommes en 2003 le malecon à la havane et
transpercés par la furie des eaux
mes vacances commence très mal je viens
de débarquer à l'aéroport et je me suis
aperçu qu'on m'avait dérobée ou que ma
valise était perdu donc je vais voir les
responsables de la compagnie d'aviation
qui me disent mais voilà on prend note
elle est peut-être égarée on sait pas
bref je me rachète quelques habits comme
ça vite fait et j'arrive à mon hôtel je
passe une soirée catastrophique
le lendemain matin coup de bol j'ai
toujours pas ma valise mais je vois un
gars qui porte ma chemise pourquoi je
sais que c'est ma chemise passe quatre
mois pour porter des chemises hawaïennes
ridicule je joue juste quand je souhaite
pour toi crient les la bonne clé parce
que les autres ne passeront pas
continue je n'ose pas aller voir le gars
mais je vais voir la direction de
l'hôtel j'ai dit mais j'ai perdu en
espagnol j'ai perdu ma valise
hier et là je vois un gars qui a ma
chemise donc il a ma valise allons
fouiller sa chambre le directeur de
l'hôtel ne veux pas je le convainc on
frappe à la porte du gars je vois le
gars qui était français en plus je le
reconnais il était dans l'avion d'hier
et je lui vie vous avez volé ma valise
et le gars dit non on fouille la chambre
on fouille tout est évidemment ce
n'était pas ma valise voilà je mets ma
chemise mais c'était tout ça c'est ça la
chute des cours très bien alors à ton
avis allison s'écoute le cas à lille
puis à paris il aurait dû c'est très
bien ce qu'on lui reproche
allison arnaque ou vérité internet c'est
de l'arnaqué
gilles c'est de l'arnaqué c'est en 1981
secondes
ouais 1989 je suis journaliste pour la
première fois jeudi au festival de
cannes
et figurez-vous que j'étais à l'époque
dans un super je travaille dans un
supermarché
donc je me suis débrouillé comme je
pouvais et figurez vous que j'y suis
allé dans l'avion du président de la
république au supermarché
non au festival de carillon cour à
l'arrière voilà c'est tout alors il a
brillé au vrai la vie auquel président
françois mitterrand alors est-ce qu'il
était sain parce que vous lui avez parlé
j'étais pas avec lui c'était un avion du
glam vous savez le le service de
transport du président est ce que vous
avez en europe
alors à votre avis merci parce que
l'imitation été pourri mais tu ris quand
même je vois que tu es sympa et
charitable avec moi sk ton avis il a
pris l'avion avec françois mitterrand
dans un avion du glam que j'ai pris
l'avion du président de la ligue 1 et
c'est un an c'était vrai c'était vrai on
perd
au sud que je vois tout à l'heure devant
lui sachez que je suis mais je vous
rassure tout de suite on a racontera pas
donc j'étais avec ma mère en voiture
sept ou huit ans est en train de
conduire à fumay donc ça sentait la
cigarette est en fait j'ai pris dans la
boîte à gants quelque chose que je
pensais être du parfum sauf que c'était
pas du tout du parfum c'était une bombe
lacrymo j'ai tout temps beau mais on a
eu un accident de voiture on a fait
trois tonneaux très bien voilà
toute ma famille est décédé dans
l'accident vous avez pris de la bombe
lacrymogène
elle était en train de conduire vous
avez aimé par tout un sac tutelle du
parfum trois tonneaux et vous étiez d'or
qu'il y avait deux dans la voiture un
année à la même et ça sera terminé sur
le dos face sur la halle sur le coffre
le conseil falot l'envers toi et ma mère
n'allait pas et h et donc du coup je
vais vous raconter l'histoire vous ces
sages essaie de la comprendre les
concurrents alors à quand la vie on est
ce qu'il y ait eu à les belles si elle
est vraie elle est impressionnante
est-ce qu effectivement elle s'est
trompée lamit de la bombe lacrymo neige
lacrymogènes pardon la tête de sa mère
et a provoqué un accident vrai et c'est
totalement vrai
on travaille avec ce musée cocteau
alors il ya moyen de lier un point il
m'est arrivé en 2008 quand je commençais
dans la radio il ya des petits boutons
sous les tables de mixage pour rappeler
comme dans les banques
si jamais un jour on est attaqué par un
mec a marre mais un petit bouton de
sécurité et on est fort mais quand on
arrive à la radio à l'utiliser ce bouton
sauf que les stagiaires ne sont pas
formés et pendant une émission
stagiaires nettoyer derrière avec une
petite éponge et avec une petite brosse
à dents la table et il a appuyé sur ce
bouton
moi j'ai continué à parler et cinq
minutes plus tard il ya des hommes
cagoulés qui sont rentrés dans gg haut
l'équivalent du gène en belgique qui est
arrivé qui a bloqué la route avec deux
camions noir et ils sont montés à une
diz quinzaine à peu près dans le studio
avec les lasers et c'était mon petit
stagiaire qui s'appelle khalid que
j'embrasse et qui est totalement ritter
en prison le rappel inscrits nous
regarde
est-ce que c'est vrai ce que sans
vouloir kelly d'appuyer sur le bouton et
a fait venir la police dans le studio de
radio en belgique
pourquoi pas c'est vraiment c'est vrai
tout à fait vrai
[Musique]